beginnen wir mit dramatischen bildern
die heute morgen aus essen kommen mitten
in der nacht reist ein feuer inferno die
bewohner eines ganzen wohnblocks aus dem
schlaf ein gebäudekomplex mit etwa 50
wohnungen steht in flammen etwa 100
personen seien aus dem komplex in
sicherheit gebracht worden so die
feuerwehr das entspreche ungefähr der
zahl der dort wohnenden menschen es ist
also noch längst nicht sicher ob alle
bewohner gerettet werden konnten es war
215 ändern 8 als es anfing zu brennen
die häuser wurden evakuiert und die
bewohner in einem nahegelegenen hörsaal
einer universität untergebracht die
krankenhäuser sind auf die einlieferung
zahlreicher verletzter vorbereitet ja
und zwischen so die meldungen ist der
brand so gut wie gelöscht aber der
anblick wir haben es gerade gesehen
gleicht einer ruine wo zuvor 50
bewohnbare wohnungen waren hat das
entfernung ein bild der zerstörung
hinterlassen
am rand von vergleichbarem ausmaß hat es
in essen noch nicht gegeben sagt die
feuerwehr und wir schalten live zu
unserem reporter frank schneider der
jetzt vor dem wohnhaus steht frank wie
ist die situation aktuell
ja die situation ist aktuell so dass das
feuer aus ist es gab eben bis vor
ungefähr drei minuten noch
nachlöscharbeiten mann hatte
ferngesteuerte monitore so nennt die
feuerwehr das mit wasser noch auf das
gebäude gericht weil die temperatur noch
immer so hoch war wir können das einmal
hinter mir zeigen es ist wirklich
unglaublich es sieht wirklich aus wie in
einem kriegsgebiet als wir hätten bomben
das gebäude getroffen das ist komplett
ausgebrannt es ist alles zerstört und
die feuerwehr hat auch selber gesagt sie
haben so etwas noch nie in der form
gesehen weil dieses feuer sich so
unglaublich schnell ausgebaut es gab
mehrere faktoren den wind aber
möglicherweise auch bauliche faktoren
aber dazu habe ich jetzt ein
gesprächspartner nämlich stehen
christoph risse den sprecher der
feuerwehr essen harris vielleicht können
sie noch einmal schildern wie hat sich
ihnen das dargestellt durch ihren
kameraden als sie ihr heute morgen
eingetroffen sind gegen ungefähr 215 um
12 15 uhr die feuerwehr alarmiert zu
einem feuer in einem mehrfamilienhaus
beim eintreffen der kollegen stellte
sich die lage so dar dass das gebäude
schon im vorderen bereich bis ins
obergeschoss im vollbrand stand und das
feuer rasend schnell ausgebreitet
glücklicherweise waren überall
rauchmelder installieren sodass die
bewohner und nachbarn entweder durch
rauchmelder geweckt worden sind oder
durch bewohner selbst stelle nicht das
gebäude noch verlassen konnten auch
darum mehr gelacht dann erstmal darin
hielten die brandausbreitung zu
verhindern und die menschenrettung
einzuleiten was uns auch relativ gut
noch gelungen ist was man sehen kann
dass der brand nicht hier auf die
nachbar stehenden gebäude die zehn meter
entfernt sind auch noch übergegriffen
ist was ja auch nicht mehr so weit weg
war wie man sieht ist ja auch hier die
scheiben geplatzten oder teilweise die
jalousien defekt jetzt ist das ja ein
neubaugebiet hier relativ neu ist die
sogenannte grüne mitte in essen sind
alles neue wohnkomplex auch sehr teure
wohnung es ist ja der erste einsatz
größere den ziel gab haben sie sich
vorstellen können dass ich ein feuer in
so einem wohnkomplex so ausbreiten kann
also man kennt das ja von bildern aus
den usa oder was ich vorher das konnten
wir es tatsächlich nicht vorstellen also
auch die kollegen die ihr da waren haben
so was in ihrer karriere doch noch nicht
gesehen also das hat die so rasend
schnell ausgebreitet da konnte man
selbst wenn man es erlebt hat konnte man
das nicht glauben jetzt gibt es ja nur
drei verletzte muss man sagen und stand
jetzt gibt es noch vermisste und wie wir
es jetzt mit dem gebäude können sie
überhaupt rein gehen um noch mal
nachzugucken sicherheitshalber ob nicht
doch noch jemand drin war aber stand
jetzt ist dass wir sukzessive anfang ein
bisschen die kräfte aus zu tauschen wir
haben stand jetzt drei verletzte
personen zurück lagen wird eine
rauchgasvergiftung
alle anderen bewohner sind in einem
nahegelegenen audi-zentrum einem
herzzentrum untergebracht worden und
werden dort betreut
wir haben vorsichtigerweise gehen wir
mal optimistisch davon aus dass ist aber
bleibt wir konnten aber leider noch
nicht alle wohnungen kontrollieren damit
ein statiker hinzugezogen und der hat
uns jetzt ausdrücklich untersagt alleine
in die wohnung zu gehen das heißt bei
jeder begehung der wohnung muss der
statiker früher gucken können wir diese
wohnung begeben ja oder nein deswegen
können wir auch als abschließend nachdem
alle wohnungen wirklich kontrolliert
worden sind sagen wir haben keine person
mehr gefunden vielen dank herr ist ja
wir hören das ist erstmal die wahnsinnig
gute nachricht drei verletzte schlimm
genug aber wenn man sich diese bilder
hinter mir nochmal anschaut und sich
vorstellt dass es dort keine toten
gegeben hat es war nachts um 2 uhr 15
alle menschen schliefen tief und fest
dann ist es wirklich grenzt es an ein
wunder dass nicht mehr opfer geben hat
aber auch hier wieder gehört rauchmelder
in den wohnungen das war wahrscheinlich
das große glück haben eben auch noch mit
einem anwohner gesprochen er sagt es
seien dramatische szenen gewesen als der
erste feuerwehrwagen eintraf der noch
gar nicht löschen konnte das waren zwei
personen die haben dann nur geschrien
leute raus leute raus und dann hat man
noch einen behinderten der im oberen
stockwerk wohnte und auf den rollstuhl
angewiesen ist runter getragen und er
sagte und aus den türen kroll der rauch
das war uns in dem moment aber egal wir
wollten ihn retten wir mussten nur raus
und er sagte als wir uns umgedreht haben
bei der ganze treppenraum schon so
verqualmt da wir keine rettung mehr
möglich gewesen also es war wirklich
dramatisch wirklich in letzter sekunde
man kann sagen dass die einzige gute
nachricht ansonsten muss man natürlich
jetzt klären und die polizei will jetzt
gleich mit einem großen team vor ort
erscheinen wie kann es zu so einer
brandausbreitung zu so einem brand
kommen und wie ist ja ausgebrochen nach
ersten informationen könnte ist auf
einem balkon angefangen haben aber wie
er sich dann so ausbreiten konnte der
orkan war da klar aber auch die
baulichen gegebenheiten müssen natürlich
geklärt weil wir hier stehen viele
solcher komplexer andere anwohner haben
alle panische angst was ist wenn es bei
uns brennt passiert uns dasselbe das ist
jetzt die grosse angst auch den nachbarn
in der nacht ist ein ganzer wohnblock
dort in flammen geraten das komplette
gebäude mit etwa 50 wohnungen stand in
flammen etwa 100 personen seien aus den
komplex in sicherheit gebracht worden
das entspreche ungefähr der zahl der
dort wohnenden menschen es ist also noch
nicht sicher ob alle bewohner gerettet
werden konnten und live in essen ist
unser reporter frank schneider frank ja
die große frage konnten alle gerettet
werden der brand ist gelöscht inzwischen
weitgehend aber so hast du uns vorhin
berichtet die feuerwehr kann noch nicht
in das gebäude hinein und alle wohnungen
durchsuchen weil die statik im moment
womöglich nicht mehr ausreichend ist
ja absolut wir können das auch einmal
gleich hinter mir zeigen wie zerstört
wird sich dieses gebäude ist wir sind
auf die rückseite gegangen und wir
können das hier mal sehen da ist eine
eingangstür aus eisen aus stahl die ist
geschmolzen der rahmen ist geschmolzen
das treppenhaus ist überhaupt nicht mehr
existent also die hitze war irrsinnig
groß und deshalb ist auch die statik des
gebäudes gefährdet und genau das ist die
befürchtung natürlich dass doch noch in
einer wohnung jemand sein könnte die
noch keiner vermisst also es gibt keine
offiziellen vermisstenanzeigen deswegen
ist die große hoffnung alle sind
rausgekommen die feuerwehr sucht jetzt
mit einer drehleiter durch die
fensterhöhlen wir hinter uns gesehen das
ist ja alles ausgebrannt in die räume
und guckt liegt noch irgendwo jemand
dann wäre das natürlich die bergung an
der leiche leben hier jemand noch
rauszuholen da gehen sie nicht mehr von
aus
aber man hat die große hoffnung ist sind
alle vorher raus gekommen wir können
auch noch mal hier am gebäudekomplex
weitergeben da sieht man auch noch mal
in eine küche ein ehemalige küche man
sieht eine dunstabzugshaube verkohlt ein
gerippe von einem kühlschrank und sonst
in dieser küche einfach nichts mehr da
die feuerwehr sagt diese hitze die muss
so irrsinnig gewesen seien und dies in
die wohnungen rhein gelaufen das heißt
es ist nicht wie sonst es brennt eine
wohnung und da ist feuer springt auf
eine weitere wohnung dann über darüber
oder daneben hier war es wohl so dass
das feuer außen am gebäude über die
dämmung und über die balkone die mit
kunststoff verkleidet sind
einfach an gebäuden muss man sich
vorstellen sich fort gefressen hat durch
den orkan bedingt natürlich auch rasend
schnell und als die feuerwehr eintraf
brannte schon alles und dann sind die
scheiben geplatzt durch die hitze und
durch die geplatzten scheiben ist das
feuer dann wieder in das gebäude rein
also ähnlich wie wir das schon mal in
london erlebt haben und auch in den usa
gesehen haben dass also ein gebäude erst
von außen bringt praktisch die hülle und
das feuer läuft dann ins gebäude rein
durch die geplatzten scheiben und das
hat man in dieser dimension jedenfalls
hier in essen aber auch hier in
nordrhein westfalen und möglicherweise
im gesamten bundesgebiet noch nie
gesehen weil es einfach so ein feuer in
der form noch nicht gab und das wären
jetzt die ermittlungen zeigen müssen
sind dass möglicherweise auch bauliche
fehler hätte das so gar nicht passieren
dürfen fragt man sieht das auch so ein
bisschen im hintergrund es ist ein sehr
moderner neuer komplex der noch nicht
allzu alt ist mit auch teuren wohnungen
dort was könnte denn eigentlich die
ursache für den brand seien
ja das ist auch noch die große frage es
gibt zwei unterschiedliche versionen
alarmiert wurde die feuerwehr über einen
wohnungsbrand es gab aber auch hinweise
dass möglicherweise ist nur auf einem
balkon gebrannt hätte ob da jetzt
möglicherweise brandstiftung fahrlässige
brandstiftung das kann ja alles mögliche
sein durch den wind entfacht eine
weggeworfene kippe die irgendwo rein
geflogen ist und dann möglicherweise
etwas entfacht hat das weiß man noch
nicht das müssen die ermittlungen der
polizei klären aber wir haben es jetzt
zu beginn auch gehört das gebäude ist
eben in seiner statik gefährdet aufgrund
der großen hitze ich hab's ja gerade
gezeigt dieses netz eine stahltür ist
geschmolzen und deshalb könnt ihr auch
stahlträger angegriffen sein und die
feuerwehr darf nur mit einem statiker
zusammen hin und wieder in den
randbereich mal rein und das heißt die
ermittler von der polizei dürfen
wahrscheinlich heute auch noch gar nicht
ins gebäude das kann sich also über tage
hinziehen hier mit der brandursache
ermittlungen denn man muss ja gucken wo
ist das feuer ausgebrochen wie hat es
sich ausgebreitet denn es gibt ja zwei
dinge die geklärt werden müssen einmal
warum ist es überhaupt ausgebrochen und
dann das zweite wie konnte es sich so
vehement ausdehnen und ein feuerwehrmann
erklärte mir eben das sind diese neuen
wärmedämmung man müsse sich das
laienhaft so vorstellen dass sein sowie
gepresste kleine kunststoff perlen die
würden zusammen gepresst und dann außen
auf das gebäude draufgeschlagen und
möglicherweise sei genau das problem
gewesen und die balkone sind alle mit
kunststoff verkleidet mit dickem
kunststoff platten und das gebäude hat
komplett außen runde um überall balkone
und da konnte das feuer sich natürlich
auch vehement ausbreiten und dann weiß
er den kunststoff schmilzt im feuer das
tropft dann runter diese hatten diese
heiße kunststoff und das bereitet sich
natürlich dann rasend schnell aus mit
diesem wind man sieht ja auch jetzt ist
es noch sehr windig hier immer noch und
das waren faktoren die eben zu diesem
verheerenden desaster geführt haben und
klar da hoffen wir dass es bei den drei
verletzten bleiben wird dann würde es in
der tat anderen wunder grenzen wenn man
diese flamme dieses inferno sieht das in
der nacht dort ausgebrochen ist und die
menschen ja im schlaf überrascht hat
vielen dank frank schneider